c'est le problème des yeux de benjamin
castaldi il vit avec les yeux fermés et
pas un problème de votre télévision dans
vous le dis il a vraiment les yeux
fermés tout le temps benjamin castaldi
on a créé ce qu'on appelle une castaldi
cam vous montrer ils vont dire ce que
voit benjamin castaldi à longueur
d'émissions simon ps qu'on peut regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
là il avait la vision arabe azzam à
castaldi toute la journée
alors j'ai un scoop sur benjamin
castaldi sachez le bazadais castaldi a
pris une grande décision et je vous la
dirai tout à l'heure et non juste avant
jean michel vous avez enquêté exactement
j'ai une information qui me vient
directement de la directrice de la plus
grande clinique de chirurgie esthétique
de paris où benjamin voulait se faire
opérer des yeux m'a-t-on dit oui
malheureusement il ya un petit problème
il lui avait proposé de lui faire un
combo serre de l'ue ont refermé la nuée
de ouvrant verser les problèmes de
flatulence
[Applaudissements]
info sérieuse quand j'ai livré un
restaurant là un ophtalmo et leur
l'ophtalmo restaurant m'a dit que c'est
normal qu'ils avaient les yeux clairs et
qu'il a pris beaucoup la lumière comme
il a pris beaucoup de lumière du coup
avec l'âge ses yeux vont se refermer
encore plus que ça se fasse enfin il va
les ongles non mais là c'est vrai
d'après vous avez vu on va revoir la
vision de benjamin castadi organise ce
que benjamin castaldi
les frères bogdanoff sont avec nous et
ils ont trouvé une solution
je vous lis ils ont une solution pour
que vous voyez à nouveau bien les frères
bogdanoff sont là ce qu'on pouvait faire
entrer igor équitable
[Musique]
ils ont ramené une rançon
alors qu'on règle jusqu'à votre dada
vous avez tout nous expliquer dans un
instant vous avez étudié le cas benjamin
castaldi
oui un camionneur vous n'avez pas dormi
la nuit on voit non mais c'est important
il a fallu prendre du temps c'est un
sujet pas du tout nous avons vu de quoi
il souffre toute l'ambition fracasse
voilà non mais c'est vrai voyez vous
avez remarqué
benjamin castaldi voit dans l'émission
très peu de choses puisqu'il a les yeux
de plus en plus fermé on s'en est rendu
compte et on a fait appel aux banques de
oui mon nom mais des scientifiques ont
lu quelques uns venus en fait exactement
oui moi c'est ce que je viens de dire et
les bogdanoff
vous avez trouvé une solution pour
benjamin castaldi déjà vous allez nous
dire à nos téléspectateurs
de quoi il souffre et d'engins instant
on le verra d'accord d'accord est
absolument voilà en fait benjamin on a
été très touché par son cas parce qu'en
fait ils sont d'une maladie très rare
une pathologie qui touche en fait les
yeux qui s'appelle l'octo plazy
dissymétrique à caractère entre grave et
rétrograde et répressive et causé au
lieu de son image par exemple quand tony
hawk tôt ça veut dire qu il est huit
fois finie et il voit huit fois plus
petit que les autres du doigt la wii
huit fois que vous avez 20 centimes et
il a toute une fois plus vous dit que
tout ça je vous le dis en tant que
problème c'est qu'il se voit lui même
très grand mais c'est vrai que l'étape
et agressive et agressif et c'est
absurde et j'en ai d'ailleurs ça
explique pourquoi il se jette sur vous
les meilleures mains exactement
il est sûr de gagner mais
dont il a fallu le soigner je sais ils
ont qu on a en a sont là soumis à un
traitement
c'est une première vous avez trouvé une
solution vous aviez la soirée we miss
you are here les yeux de benjamin
castaldi
il avait une passion vous avez misé ou
un petit peu soumis la même trempe
oui on sait on a dit la même chose
qu'ils ont misé sur le menton et vous
allez voir le résultat
et tous les bagages à main
tu as changé de nom le vrai problème il
n'écrit pas les refermer sur sa non non
non non le problème c'est que on est
tous mis tout ce que tu sais bien
les bottes ballon va faire des petits
tests
benjamin on va voir si tu vois bien on
va voir ce que tu vois d'accord on va
faire un test comme chez l'ophtalmo
attention c'est parti
regardez attention vous y voilà la
dernière auquel cas elle est d'accord
très bien deuxième bail xps bzm mrtv f
le ncx oseille delhi voit ivoire